flying is hard it took human flight
pioneers decades to come up with a
design that would stay in the air
there were many experiments some better
than others some stood the test of time
and so it was when animals learnt to fly
we know of three different groups of
flying vertebrates birds bats and
pterosaurs but they didn't just spring
into the air one day fully formed they
too experimented with flight a fossil
dig in herb a province near Beijing in
China has unearthed a fossil that
reveals the breath of experimenting that
went on this squashed beauty is a newly
discovered species of dinosaur called Yi
Qi it's about the size of a large pigeon
Yi Qi is related to the dinosaur
ancestors of modern-day birds but
although it had feathers it didn't have
wings like theirs instead it had these
long fingers that supported a membrane a
bit like a bats wing scientists are
scratching their heads about how it
might have flown it might have flapped
like a bat or glided a bit like this
flying squirrel it's impossible to know
where the extra bony bit of arm would
have been positioned during years life
but the team believed that Yi would have
been able to glide here's what they
think it might have looked like
graceful isn't it
some further analyses of its weight
suggest it was rather back heavy and may
have risked stalling in the air whatever
it did it just adds to the diversity we
now know must have existed early in the
bird family tree and we can only be
sorry that this little guy went extinct
while pigeons survived
you